for all of the good that Superman's done
and over the past 80 years he's done a
lot of good he can also be kind of
obnoxious but there's a difference
between passive aggression and outright
super villainy and while Superman rarely
crosses it he often toes the line
sometimes Superman thinks he's acting in
humanity's best interest and just makes
a bad judgment call
other times he pushed to extremes dog
occasionally it's mind control or some
alternate dimensions a ninis every now
and then as rare as it is the Man of
Steel just gets downright nasty here are
just a few of the worst thing Superman
has ever done get out of town when
Superman first appeared he was less of
the inspirational figure that fans know
and love today and more of a
rough-and-tumble progressive we've
tackled social issues in his first
appearance in Action Comics number one
Superman declares himself the champion
of the oppressed and spends most of his
time fighting crooked landlords and
domestic abusers by Action Comics number
eight
Superman tackles juvenile delinquency by
getting metropolis bombed after the
local underprivileged teams don't seem
too interested in reforming from their
criminal ways
Superman exhibits an extremely flawed
understanding of basic sociology and
blames these kids being jerks on their
ramshackle homes with the true culprit
clearly identified Superman is inspired
by a devastating Florida hurricane and
goes to work demolishing the slums with
his bare hands this catches the
attention of the Army who inadvertently
finished Superman's job by dropping
bombs on the Man of Steel ultimately
government replaces the slums with a
series of nice modern apartment
buildings thereby gentrifying the
neighborhood and forcing a travel as
poor out of town but hey at least crime
is down right hitting a nerve while
growing up in Smallville Clark Kent had
two close friends Pete Ross who knew
Clark was secretly Superboy and Lana
Lang his on-again off-again love
interest Pete ended up becoming proof
that even if your best friends were the
most powerful being in the solar system
your life can still fall apart pretty
quickly in DC Comics presents number 13
Superman runs across the nervion an
advanced warrior race of conquering
aliens who abduct Pete Ross's son
Jonathan and it's up to Superman to
rescue him easy stuff right but before
Superman can make his move the Legion of
super-heroes arrived from the future and
tell the Man of Steel to back off
little Jonathan Ross is destined to
become nerv ins greatest warrior
instrumental to the course of future
events and galactic peace it all adds up
and Superman leaves the kid with the
scare
aliens needless to say Papa Pete doesn't
take Superman's news very well he goes
berserk and eventually ends up locked
away in a mental institution spending
all of his time ripping up posters of
Superman
baby bump it's pretty obvious that the
bodies of humans and Kryptonians are
very different they may look the same
but Superman can fly and carry cars
around without breaking a sweat
we grunt with exhaustion when we reach
for the remote on the other side of the
couch and when it comes to Superman and
Lois Lane making little half-human
half-alien babies those conversations
are best left to the sweaty backroom of
the comic shop well there and Adventures
of Superman annual number three in the
story a mysterious being named Waverider
takes a glimpse into Clark Kent's future
and makes a shocking discovery after
Lois and Clark get married their unborn
child kills Lois by giving her a
super-powered womb kick seriously in his
despair
Superman flees the planet essentially
attempting suicide it doesn't work of
course after getting blasted by an alien
missile Superman is rescued by maxima an
alien warrior princess who has the hots
for their eventual romance leads to an
alien invasion of Earth and Superman
leaving earth for good but not until he
makes out with his new girlfriend on his
wife's fresh grave classy take it sleazy
years before Paris Hilton's naked
night-vision rock made the front page
Superman tried to make the celebrity sex
tape the same with a little help from
one of Darkseid's former lieutenants she
aptly named please please by the way was
banished from its home planet by the
most evil being in the universe for
being too much of a perv in Action
Comics number 592 Superman tracks fellow
hero big Barda the metropolis is very
own suicide swamp where Superman
discovers that Barda has been
brainwashed by fleas to produce a line
of popular adult films Superman tries to
rescue Barda but ultimately falls under
sleeves is controlled too and flees does
exactly what you'd expect
he takes Barda and Superman to the local
pornographer and make some naughty
videos then big barda's husband shows up
to Superman's credit his sense of
morality
pretty strong even while under mind
control so the production doesn't make
it much further than the opening moment
and the director complains that Superman
has all the sex appeal of a side of beef
still the side of his wife sucking face
with the Man of Steel is enough to set
mr. miracle off and he frees both heroes
from sleazes mind control
neither one totally knew what happened
and neither one wanted to talk about it
but thankfully no Superman looking
babies popped up at the DC Universe nine
months later murder and madness like
lots of superheroes Superman has a
strict no murder policy but how did he
arrive at that span the answer lies in
Superman number 22 one of the most
controversial Superman stories ever told
Superman finds himself in a pocket
dimension where a trio of Kryptonian
soldiers including an alternate reality
version of General Zod have wiped out
all life on Earth except for Bruce Wayne
lex luthor and a synthetic life-form who
goes by Supergirl Superman and his
allies put up a valiant fight but
Superman is forced to take drastic
measures first Superman robs them of
their powers using gold kryptonite but
that's not enough powered or not
Zod vowed to track Superman down and
destroy his earth Superman doesn't take
the threat lightly he decides abandoning
the villains on a dead world isn't
enough he has to kill them Superman
looks on as the three phantom zone
criminals beg for their lives in the
face of deadly green kryptonite then
returns home eventually a guilty
Superman decides to never kill again but
it's too late for Zod the damage has
been done mostly to Superman's mine in
the following days he's plagued by guilt
he's not sleeping well blacking out in
the middle of missions meanwhile a
masked crime fighter named gang Buster
has been picking up Superman flack using
much harsher methods unlike Superman
gang Buster has no problem beating goons
within an inch of their life the
vigilantes one-man war on crime
ultimately pits gang Buster against the
Guardian if you've read comics before
it's not hard to see where this is going
and Adventures of Superman number 450
gang busters costume is ripped in half
revealing Superman's suit underneath as
it turns out
Superman's guilt drove him a little
nuts and splitted personality into
confused and angry
Superman heads to space for a few months
to clear his head proving without a
doubt that his real superpower is not
having to keep a steady job thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]